[Music]
hi and welcome back to vm end to end a
show where we have a vm enthusiast and a
vm skeptic or former vm skeptic hash out
all things vms if you remember the show
from last season we talked about
reliability automation cost and all of
the benefits that you can get from cloud
native vms but there's still some things
i'm confused on so i brought brian back
in to talk about it brian hi i need to
know why i can't have just one giant
super machine that just works instead of
all these little flimsy parts
that would be amazing wouldn't it you
know just kind of an infinitely large
machine um but that is not a thing and
you know this season we're going to
bring some guests in to kind of dig
deeper into some of these concepts so
to tell us
you know kind of more about why that
isn't a thing and how to get reliability
out of things we brought in steve mcgee
hey steve
hey guys how's it going hi steve glad to
have you here can can you tell us a
little bit about yourself and who you
are
sure um i'm steve mcgee i was an sre in
google for about 10 years and then then
i left and i became a customer of cloud
and i learned how to cloud and how to
use all the different clouds and just
how difficult it is actually um to kind
of make decisions and and
you know stuff like that um and then i
came back to google to to help more
customers do exactly that i tend to
focus on reliability as because my
background was in site reliability
engineering
see this is great because something i'm
trying to figure out is
people that are focused on reliability
you would think that or at least i would
think that and brian has said that i
might be a little misguided here that
just having one piece of hardware that
you upgrade and put a lot of resources
into is going to be a lot more reliable
than having lots of smaller parts that
have to communicate that can all fail
so where am i going wrong here
yeah i mean your intent is is correct
like it would be sweet if we just had
like a perfectly you know infinitely
dense infinitely fast computer you know
when you when you work on a system on
your on your laptop you know the whole
phrase you know it works on my machine
like what's the problem uh when we go
into production we're scaling up and we
have to scale up because we don't want
to like have a service for like one
person we hopefully want it for like
many people right potentially even
around the world or something like that
so um being able to scale up into
production means that we run into like
actual laws of physics so you know speed
of light comes into play like density of
material like you can't go so dense that
everything catches fire for example that
would be bad um and so that means we
have to start spreading things out um
what it really really means is that
we're we're taking what was one computer
and we're spreading it across sort of
time and space and we're using many
computers instead
so
i hope that kind of helps understand
like what what the basic problem is here
it really does because uh we talked
about this a lot brian hammered home a
point last season he said
a cloud vm is a slice of a data center
more so than it was a slice of one
specific machine and so it seems like
that's playing out here
but what i don't understand is google
google touts its reliability and being
able to be up for a long time but how is
it able to do that with so many parts
that are constantly going to fail like a
disc if you think about like um
what it what it used to be like like um
during like the the dot-com boom we used
to call these like gold-plated servers
like we would make like the most
expensive solid
server that you could ever have like
many
nicks and minis power supplies and many
everything's and like hot swappable this
and that and
those were pretty awesome like they they
lasted uh really really well but they
were super expensive and it turns out
that just kind of putting all your eggs
into the basket of like making the one
machine really reliable only gets you a
little bit of the
kind of the the return because you still
have to have some downtime for like
maintenance and and and scaling up and
things like that and so what we found
inside of google is that uh we found we
actually wanted to
horizontally scale which is like adding
more machines
um at a time in order to like you know
achieve you know planet-wide scale like
like have billions of users for example
you can't fit billions of users on one
very expensive machine so
once you start horizontally scaling
using the most expensive machine
possible with very little like you know
with marginal return doesn't really make
sense and so this is where we introduced
instead of having like a really solid
base we introduced resilience at many
layers in the stack and it turns out
that is
way better to to
for for the for the service it's more
economical and and it actually allows
you to move faster which which is sounds
crazy but it's true
this shows up in a lot of places in
google cloud like around the vms you
know like the vms themselves you know
are kind of insulated you know to some
degree from the underlying systems
through live migration
we've got different zones of separation
between them we got kind of load
balancers so you can kind of hit
different pieces
um
but it it feels like there's like a core
principle here or to
i don't know if if you could talk a
little bit more about that
yeah i mean um so i was a
you know i went to school in computer
science so i consider myself like a
computer scientist i guess or a software
engineer and like i think everyone who's
super into computer science knows like
the one holy thing is like layers of
abstraction right uh abstraction solves
everything um so
really this is what we're talking about
here is we're gonna have many layers of
abstraction um and i i kind of jokingly
refer to this as like the machoyshka
doll which is like those little nesting
dolls you've seen um where you have like
ins you know at the very middle the tiny
little doll is like your cpu and then
you it goes up to like a machine and
that you know has has a vm around it and
then like that's in the rack and like
it's in a you know data center and then
the data center is part of a zone which
is then i mean part of a region and so
at every layer of this stack if you're
able to
kind of
perform some resilience engineering to
to make sure that you can take advantage
of that sort of layer of the stack this
is where you get really like it's like
defense and depth right so you're able
to
handle failures at any level of this
stack because you know disks fail cpus
can go out you can get you know solar
flares can cause memory corruption you
can have someone can you know cut a
fiber line to a data center right and
the whole building could potentially go
offline we have floods happen i mean
they're rare you know fires happen
they're rare too
so there's lots of potential
failure modes that you have to consider
and they happen at many of these levels
so being aware of all those and having
mitigations ready for them is super
important it's funny we're calling it
like virtual machines in the cloud it's
really virtual machines and virtual
disks and virtual load balancers and
that's right i really liked what you
said in the previous episode that you're
getting like a slice of a data center
because it's we're able to take all
these component parts and like present
them to a customer as like this nice
abstraction like it's this computer with
this disk and it has this network and in
actuality it might be
like the one disk you have is actually
three disks but you know we're not
really showing you all three disks it's
just like magically kind of giving it
you know this resilience and redundancy
to you yeah i see how
being able to abstract away the layer
underneath yourself and says i don't
care exactly which zone is under this
region as long as one of them is up i'm
fine that actually makes sense and it
makes sense why we wouldn't want one
super computer because it'd be hard to
do that
but then now you have to start managing
all these separate like
zones and vms and all all this extra
complexity that comes in which is one of
the downsides of abstraction sometimes
how does how does google handle that
a good question um i i work with a lot
of companies that ask exactly this they
say like great you want us to spread all
of our computers around the planet that
doesn't sound like a pain in the butt at
all you know it sounds like well how in
the heck do you expect me to do like
deal with that um and again the answer
comes back to abstraction right um so
when you think about it like you have
you know one vm and it's like the next
the first step you're going to get is
you know many vms right so we put these
together we put them behind a load
balancer we call this a service
if you're familiar with kubernetes it's
pretty much the same idea where you have
a bunch of vms and you have like an
entry point that talks to all of them
um if you can then take this service and
you can run it across multiple zones
we can now we can call this a regional
service because it now lives across many
of these zones in one region and then if
you can get that regional service in
many regions
i call this a distributed service
there's like there's no canonical name
for that right now but like the idea is
that it's it's many of these services
but they all kind of do the same thing
and they represent the same like you
know business need um and so you're able
to now handle like regional level events
as well
okay okay i'm i'm putting all this
together i'm trying to like really piece
this together because it's
it's it's still hard to me to think like
these things can go down so often and
that gives you more reliability because
you're layering them on top of each
other maybe brian you're always good at
giving me concrete examples is there
like where do we use this in google
cloud
so i think the the most common example
is when you when you have uh multiple
vms that are kind of doing the same job
maybe they're a web server or something
like that and you put a load balancer in
front of them and like this shows up in
physical you know
installations and it shows up in the
cloud it's it's maybe the most common
example of this you know so you have
like one endpoint and you have multiple
different backends that can
do the work and if one of them goes away
the work still happens um so i think
that's like my favorite kind of specific
example but
steve is there like a
more general principle at work here
um yeah totally um so uh an analogy to
to think about is uh just think about
boats in in the water right like
physical boats um if you poke a hole in
the bottom of your your dinghy like
you're gonna have a bad day right that's
no good um so this is we call this one
failure domain your little dinghy is a
failure domain because there's only one
like floor to it right and if you put a
hole anywhere in that floor it's gonna
flood it's not great um but then now
think of a bigger ship think of like a
container ship or some giant you know
like vessel of some kind um they're kind
of like a bunch of little boats tied
together because they have these things
called bulkheads so you can i mean i
wouldn't do this but you could poke a
hole in the bottom of like one hole in
the bottom of one of these big ships and
it would be fine because it would do is
it would fill up that bulkhead but the
rest of the boat is so buoyant that it
stays floating so essentially like
you're taking these things that could
fail with a hole and you stick them
together and now the system as a whole
doesn't fail with that same failure mode
right so we've got so that's exactly
what's going on with our vms and load
balancer kind of thing
um like how does
like
how do we decide
you know you know how does this work
like how do you so if you've got vms and
load balancers and and uh these these
different bits and you mentioned you
know zones and regions and like just you
know distributed services how do we
how do we reason about this like how do
we decide you know
how much complexity we're going to kind
of put into this
a good question like uh yeah that was
kind of like the abstract academic
answer and so now like let's let's talk
about like reality steve um
this is this is an important thing to to
understand like what um
a level of availability you can expect
from from the systems you're building on
top of like how often do we get a hole
in the bottom of a boat like can we get
a number that would be nice
the way that we
suggest people think about it
is that for something that lives in one
zone uh we say it's going to be
available 99.9 percent of the time
specifically we say it's designed to be
available 99.9 of the time uh that is
basically it means it's going to be down
or unavailable for 40 minutes a month
and it's important to think that's not
like the best case scenario or the worst
case scenario like that's something you
can pretty much count on so it's it's
pretty much going to happen
similarly if you if you have something
that is across many zones in a region
we call that four nines it's 99.99
available and the way to think about
that is it's 40 minutes a year
of downtime
which is actually pretty good like
computers stay up quite a lot you know
40 minutes in an entire year is it's a
tiny i mean we know exactly how big of a
fraction it is but sometimes maybe
that's still not acceptable for you but
it's up to like what it is that you're
putting on these computers like are you
okay with with those three nines or
those four nines
and and you have to make a decision on
on what's appropriate for you
i i get this now because basically
you're saying okay i have two computers
that are up uh
40 min they're only down 40 minutes
every year if we layer them over each
other when one down the other one's not
down we're good um and so it's just
interesting seeing like
all of this that comes in that you have
to manage on your own like i wonder if i
have to come in as the developer and be
like
okay i have to schedule this computer to
be up uh watching for the other one to
be down or is this something that the
infrastructure can start to take care of
for you yeah the the good news is that
like this is this is a problem that
inside of google for the past you know
20 years we've been dealing with and so
we've come up with a bunch of solutions
basically a bunch of like improvements
to the system and we're bringing those
to cloud customers and so for example
like we know that sometimes you have to
power down a rack of machines or
something like that and like if your
computer is on that you know if your
server is on that rack like what do you
do like that's a real bummer like should
we tell you ahead of time or something
like that uh but we we instead we we
built this thing called live migration
which basically takes like the soul of
your machine like the running system the
running software and like it transports
it magically across the room or whatever
to another machine and that way we can
safely power down this rack bring it
back up again maybe we had to like
replace a fuse or something i'm not
really sure
and basically it's one less thing for
you to worry about
and when i said before that machines are
designed to have 99.9 percent of
availability it accounts for stuff like
this so this is this is
how we're giving you 99.9 availability
it's there's a bunch of other stuff too
like sometimes the building we need to
do maintenance on or or maybe the
machine itself is has a problem or who
knows there's all kinds of things that
could go wrong we sort of aggregate all
that risk into one number and then we
give you that expectation and you
basically don't have to worry about all
those weird things that could go wrong
you just know this machine is going to
be up 99.9 of the time so there's a
there's a whole bunch of um these kind
of edge cases i guess if you will
that are just handled because you're
running a vm in a cloud you know
instead of you know on an individual
physical machine
so we've got we've got all of those
we've got
these um tools like this something
similar is happening at the disc level
you know we've got load balancers that
are you know built out of lots of
machines kind of data center level
things
um we've got
groups of vms like managed instance
groups and then like zones and regions
and all this kind of stuff
um
but then
we
i don't know like then some of it like
it's to the app kind of level problem
right
um
like you're saying you want to design an
application that can handle this this 40
minutes of downtime a year too as well
that's interesting yeah so okay so so we
get to the point where we can trust the
vms and then kind of build from there i
guess
um
yeah the the important point is to kind
of know what what level of trust you can
put into the vm and what you're really
doing is you're you're putting that
trust into the hands of your cloud
provider and you're saying like
look just tell me what it's going to be
and like on gcp for our vms we tell you
it's going to be 99.9 uh for for one vm
in one zone and then it just means that
you get to put that all that out of your
your your mind and you can
trust that number is going to be true
and now you have to work around it it's
important that you don't think that that
number is
you know it's close enough to a hundred
let's just say it's a hundred percent
because like that's not true like if you
make a distinction between 9.9 and 100
you're going to make
actually radically different design
choices in your application
you're going to start to introduce
things like retries or you're going to
introduce things like checkpointing or
you're going to like allow your service
to you know to potentially live in two
places at the same time like what if one
request comes in here and one request
comes in there and like this one's up
and this one's not like
like now that you've allowed a little
bit of failure into your understanding
of the model
you change the way you think about
designing your system and that was
actually like to me that was one of the
fundamental things that made google
succeed from the very beginning was that
we designed our systems to allow some
form of failure and then we just added
that resiliency over and over and over
again all the way through the stack
this is so interesting because uh the
way you just worded that it finally made
it click for me uh by planning for
failure it doesn't matter what the
failure is because i have the case
covered it's going to be some delay to
getting this information to me in some
way so i'll retry it i'll do something
like that
and then that allows you to build more
resilience and reliability
again it's an abstraction away from the
core thing i don't care why it's down
let me abstract to put it in a real
world there's some important use cases
where this matters and that's why
there's so much effort going into this
thought
that's right um it's important to to not
try to get the highest level of
reliability out of absolutely everything
because you're going to have some you
know
websites or services or or whatever that
like can be down it's no big deal you
know it's not not a problem but like
there are other services which are
actually
really important so let's say there's a
service out there that like um responds
when someone needs to like get a new
delivery of oxygen tanks to some you
know medical center or something like
that like we should probably make sure
that that one works you know like most
of the time and even if like you make a
request and like
it doesn't work right away but we know
that like once we put it in like it you
know was received and like someone will
take action on it or something like that
like
that's just kind of a silly example but
like there are more and more of these
services that are becoming more and more
important to the world because frankly
we're just putting more of our society
online
so i think covet is actually an
interesting time to go through this
whole like reliability effort because we
saw a lot of services became more and
more important to individuals uh like in
an accelerated kind of way like it was
already getting more important but
during the last couple years it went
like really steep so think about video
conferencing for school kids or you know
just ordering things from home like
being able to do this online is becoming
more important so making sure that you
can do it when you want to do it uh is
is more of a big deal even than it used
to be
yeah things getting uh very real like
more of our life goes online like it
matters more and
more and more critical so okay this has
been amazing um i think we're gonna have
to wrap up this one but i feel like
there's a lot more to talk about here
and so steve would you be up for coming
back and talk
specifically about when you decide you
know what kind of what questions you ask
you know about how to whether you're
going to try to get another nine and
then how do you actually do it
uh yeah i think i can make a
sign um i think it's an important thing
like people really want to want to hear
about this stuff so i'd love to come
back hey well thank you so much steve
brian thank you so much if you're
listening at home uh please write in the
comments if there's anything you've
learned about reliability i know i
learned a few things maybe you do thank
you
[Music]